level that you never gonna get back
please always push it over to the brain
free never respect you respect that
British reach that keeps you Beach tight
tag
[Music]
the Dark Knight Returns book 3 opens on
one of the weirdest Batman moments
either ever be weirder Lyndell boy
Batman dress in a full fat suit tackles
a woman who looks like Brigitte Nielsen
with swastika nipples it's clear this is
where crazy Frank Miller started coming
across even today it's slightly garish
and in my opinion is the books lowest
point on first reading this I can
remember it completely derail in the
boot and it's aged very poorly because
of it I don't know why Batman would even
have this suit he has the appearance of
a burn victim and if it was to be picked
to be inconspicuous then I don't know
how it achieves that it stands out like
Will Smith's ear and the villain will
have you wanting to run to the mountains
like rocky for lots of Brigitte Nielsen
joke but she was in Rocky for it's
certainly a sign of the monstrosity that
Frank would turn into hinting at the
sexual BDSM that would lay a plague as
boobs and it feels completely out of
place especially when a child is running
round in a Robin costume in the
background what the [ __ ] is going on
it's within this chapter that Superman's
introduced wilds Miller's often
criticized for his depiction of the Big
Blue Boy Scout to me it's very
analytical Superman at this point I
become very one-dimensional as a
character in this book is a government
Lackey and due to his allegiances you
might not always be on the right side
but it's very realistic to me even
though Superman isn't realistic
owl but imagine yet if Superman existed
today even hack this side with Trump's
policies which go completely against
equality and human rights so it's very
contradict
as an idea at one point in the book we
see Batman common that we kill because
we've made it too easy that's the
perfect analysis of Superman within this
book throughout the story he murders
soldiers and whilst governments often
present this is acceptable because it's
part of war you can murder someone as
long as it's part of all I simply can't
agree if murder is wrong then it's wrong
period the government are happy to
sanction it when it fits their deeds and
because of this people give it a pass
melodye constructed the world's most
famous superhero in a clear way whilst
allowing Batman to be a voice of dissent
amongst others this created a beautiful
dichotomy between the two and it makes
for a really gripping read like someone
out of a Calvin Klein advert the to
converse and it's interesting to see
their opposing ideologies that hint that
why the Dark Knight had to retire
mirroring this we see Commissioner
Gordon retire passing the role to Ellen
yindel to disagree heavily on the
subject of Batman and when she puts out
a warrant for the Caped Crusader's
arrest it's clear she's making a solid
stance against vigilantism throughout
the book she learns of Batman's
importance and once I don't necessarily
like the characters beginning by the end
she represents the doubters and those
who would come around to the idea that
extremism must be dealt with in extreme
ways I've always loved Batman when he
takes on the police and any other time
by the sounds of it yo [ __ ] so I was
head over heels with the Joker's escaped
during the day of endocrine show we
often see tales of police murdering
innocent people so it's refreshing to
see someone who solely represents
beating the crap out of policemen as
they're often shown to be careless it's
just the way the news can represent it
yeah and this is deconstructing that in
the backdrop of this battle we witness
the Joker murder hundreds of audience
members on a chat show to me this really
represents our obsession with celebrity
no matter how wicked they are we often
put entertainment over morals and it's
easy to see how the public consciousness
would be desperate to see the Joker be
interviewed they get exactly what they
wish for and is gassing of the audience
leaving them all
the death speaks volumes to our
ignorance when dealing with serious
matters we ignore the constant tragedy
and death that goes on around us and
continue to smile as if nothing has
happened the audience dies laughing as
we cut to Superman murdering soldiers in
a foreign country who are doing nothing
other than protecting their land it's
very very political building towards a
climax we get several people openly
questioning Batman's reasons for never
killing the Joker sprawled across the
new sections the doubt clearly creeps
into the dark nights of consciousness
why has he never killed the Joker is it
because without him he has no purpose
these questions make us doubt all the
good that the hero is done but it
certainly cements his morality after
seeing how many Joker murders upon his
escape the tension rises within the
story due to US questioning whether
Batman will finally do what many of you
is necessary this is outstanding and
completely heightens the drama and it
leaps off the page as we go into their
final battle it's a shame that Batman
murdered so many people in Batman V
Superman I wish they hadn't been forced
not filmer Batman never kills but
Superman was so dangerous that he had to
break his one rule in order to save the
world that movie completely misses that
mark and it turns the Caped Crusader
into a serial killer taking away any
extra attention that could have been
there in the final battle like imagine
how good it would have been yet if
Batman had been stood over Superman with
his spear knowing that if he killed them
he would save humans but he would lose
all of his humanity that's why it's so
good in this book the fact that you
believe Batman's finally gonna murder
the Joker adds to the tension because
you know it's a no-win situation it's
not gonna be returning the Joker to
Arkham there's gonna be no going back
and being in Batman in the Joker facing
off in the Hall of Mirrors before
finalizing their encounter
the tunnel of love there's very little
subtlety for this statement that Miller
is making that doesn't detract from it
though and it's a brutal personal
conflict
Batman loses control and snaps the
Joker's neck and once he doesn't kill
the Joker it's still a small victory for
the Clown Prince of Crime the Joker
twists his own neck breaking it and
killing himself in the process he dies
laughing safe in the knowledge that the
witnesses will say Batman did it meaning
that the Dark Knight's reign of justice
will now be fully questioned by the
authorities
it's a hoarding showdown that's stuck
with me for years since I first wrote it
The Joker's final moments will stick
with you forever the white face brandish
with a massive smile as something
rustles out his body when it leaves
ending the book well the third issue
starts off as the whole ops lowest point
it quickly gathers pace and delivers on
a final showdown that's satisfying
between the Joker and Batman
it's the perfect summation of their
relationship and it's the only way that
it could have possibly ended there is a
slight imbalance in quality in this
issue but by far the good outweighs the
bad and because of it I'm giving it an
8.5 out of 10 so what did you think of
the book and below let me know thanks
very much for checking out this video
I'm reviewing the final chapter next
week and my run-up to the Dark Knight 3
the master race review so make sure you
subscribe my channel to get my thoughts
on that book and the Dark Knight strikes
again when I review that thanks very
much take care peace